[Music]
of all the great champions from the past
who do you think would be amazing at
playing chess 960 you would choose some
of the more sort of free-flowing players
I mean fissuring himself I would choose
maybe tal you know a player who flew
sort of invite by the seat of his pants
and depended on intuition a great deal
in general it would reward someone with
a good feeling for dynamics for a good
feeling with the initiative and how to
place their pieces in the aggressive way
because it's not you don't really rely
on like the traditional opening concepts
but it would be interesting to see for
example a guy like cabo blanco play i'm
guessing Petrosyan would be really good
and just nice to see because he loved to
improve his pieces he loved the
maneuvering pieces it was good detecting
danger something I'm not really good at
Braunstein maybe our pretty sure Fisher
would be very strong too and maybe even
carpool there's all these answers I
could say Bobby Fischer sensi he more or
less came up with the concept and kappa
blanka also i think would make sense
because he tended to prefer nights over
bishops I think that Karpov will be very
very good because he doesn't like theory
but what people is just really great
might be cup of lanka because he also
didn't like theory it seems you seemed
to invite Karpov his best years I think
he has really good feeling about the
pieces I don't think he was very good as
a the apotheke but he was really strong
with the composition of the pieces and
he had some inner touch I mean the one
person that sort of immediately came to
mind as somebody who I would not name in
my first five let's say would be but we
need not because he wouldn't necessarily
be better than but because I think he
was so methodical and so reliant on the
proper scientific method for from what I
know about him as a person I think he
would be a bald
had the you know perversion of the
classical game so I don't think they
weren't necessarily his cup of tea I
would definitely say that some of the
world champions though like Botvinnik or
Karpov would probably be terrible at 960
so maybe st. Lucia
maybe we should invite Anatole here next
year the expectation that 960 will just
completely overturn the established
world order let's say we obviously don't
have enough sample size and we will not
get to the proper sample size in quite
some time yet but for instance there is
now online qualification going on for
the world championship which will be
held later this year in the five
qualifiers that were held so far number
one seed played number two seed in the
final I think in four out of five so
people who are generally good at chess
non shockingly they're enough to be good
at 10:16 I dunno they it's still chess
and I don't believe that you can have
some great talents that could thrive in
960 while not doing well in classical
chess it's it's the same nonsense as we
heard many times about bullets and rapid
yeah some players could do a bit better
than rapid and bliss but at the end of
the day it still will be madness and VL
Kaoru it just it still is a usual
suspect so I think we see more and more
960 it will just prove that at the end
of the day it's still the game of chess